[Music]
all right
so the story here is about a youtuber
from south korea
who's facing criticism
oh criticism with the k korea-ism
after his review of a restaurant uh
his false review of a restaurant was
forced to shut the restaurant down
like this restaurant was supposed to
shut down wait so he lied
about well he had a perspective yeah he
got it wrong
he got it wrong and this caused the
restaurant to ultimately
be shut down so sad i think they have
some laws
like against reviews that are negative
can be considered defamation out there
oh please have that out here
the restaurant owner right now is like
seeking some sort of
of law for youtubers to not have that
kind of like
immense power over over restaurants
could extort people that way
you kind of can here's the story so this
channel
the channel name is high end tree so he
uploaded
a review video of an all you can eat soy
sauce marinated
crab restaurant that sounds delicious
that's delicious
and so he posted that on december 7th
and in the video
he says that he saw grains of rice in
the refilled
marinated crab and he raised the
suspicion that the restaurant
might be reusing its food but the thing
is they they just refilled
like his plate so the rice was actually
from previous dish that he had just
finished eating
oh this but he didn't he didn't know
that and
he's that stupid he didn't realize that
this was the same plate that he used and
then they refilled it
apparently not and so he posted this
video his
his channel has about 700 000
subscribers at that time
and so that review video no no
no no no no no no no no
no no no and so that review led to
a quick impact on the reference oh
[ __ ] [ __ ]
so he has that much influence to where
word went out and people are like
we're not going there because mr mukbang
leaving like [ __ ] up like malicious
comments about the restaurant and saying
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with this
russian all this stuff right
torched them and then so the restaurant
owner
said that within a few hours he
like the restaurant workers were
commenting on that
on that video and saying like we don't
reuse our food like that was your same
food or whatever trying to explain
apparently he says that their comments
were blocked
and oh so it sounds like he's accusing
this dude of blocking the comments but i
don't know
and then so um not until december 11th
he posted a video
saying i went to apologize to the owner
of the restaurant for creating the video
without thinking about my impact but the
owner did not feel comfortable about
filming another video i should have gone
about making the video with accurate
facts and i'm truly sorry for my
ignorance
because he left this video up and it
reached a million views oh no
oh no no no good conversion rate by the
way
good conversion rate [ __ ] that breaks my
heart dude like as a small business
owner like
we are all small business owners and we
[ __ ]
grind the [ __ ] out so that we can make
[ __ ]
you know our our dreams come true and it
ain't easy dude like we don't have
support
that's got to be defamation though like
even an american sense because that
affected the business
from false accusations it should right
it should
so yeah they were saying that by the
time he were he uploaded that second
video the damage was already done the
restaurant was already like horrible
reputation
already had to shut down and so
um so the owner said in less than two to
three hours after the youtuber posted
the video our staff members left the
restaurants explanation multiple times
that we do not reuse our food and we
could provide
the entire footage from our security
camera but our comments got blocked so
other people could not see them so he
was
doing that it sounds like it and then
yeah and so he and then that video where
he posted on december 11th i think it
was that one that i watched
i checked the thumbs down it was 88 000
thumbs down
so what is he gonna do to make it right
like he went to apologize but that's not
gonna bring the business back
yeah i think it's he should probably pay
for damages he needs to get sued my
livelihoods were lost and all that just
because he
did that how many employees do you think
yeah but he made an apology video though
and he got more followers and he got
more money
some followers he lost about like 30k or
something that's
oh a [ __ ] dropping 600 000
he's gonna keep gaining he's trying to
get that play button that's that's not
easy
but yeah so the owner said i am really
frustrated and i want to know if it's
possible to prevent youtubers abuse and
tyranny which is scarier than the
coronavirus and i am petitioning for
laws and regulations so that
self-employed people can comfortably
focus on their business i think
he already violated a law it's a
defamation law like you can't
publicly make false statements about a
business and then
hurt the business and then if they can
obviously in this situation prove that
money and business was lost because of
this guy's actions
at least in the states that falls under
defamation
clearly i love tubers who carry out
because they're always like
you know i have a platform i'm happy now
i'm like i can really make this trouble
for you
oh god the problem is is even if they
regulated youtube like tick tock does
that too
twitter does that too like they're gonna
have to shut down all all social media
because every platform has people that
do this yeah i mean there's already laws
though
that prevent that thing from happening
or
you can go after it was like a challenge
going on where
youtubers would go to the lowest yelp
rated
nail salons restaurants and they would
go and and check it out for themselves
i loved watching those yeah but it's
[ __ ] up you know what i mean like
i don't know i think it's just really
[ __ ] up to like play on
on with someone's [ __ ] livelihood
well it depends
okay so my whole thing is like
quality of service right like yes if you
you could be a business owner but if
you're a stubborn
[ __ ] up business owner you deserve for
your business to crash
just like we've been to businesses where
you're like why the [ __ ] do you even run
this if you hate working
right so in some of those reviews
uh i've most of them actually people
just experience it and then they're just
like wow this is broken or like this or
they're just
having a good time i don't like the ones
where people are just
going in and like they're trying to find
[ __ ] and drama
yeah i don't like when they go in there
and they're already like kind of
laughing well because that's getting
rewarded
any sort of drama gets way more views
and passed around
like there needs to be some sort of
conflict or something like ooh juicy in
there or else it doesn't go as viral
so they yeah they conjure up but i
actually love the social media aspect of
business regulating
like reviews all that stuff and the
reason for that is because
in the past multiple people can get
burned by a business
like let's say the business owners shady
and just scams people like it's a
bad auto mechanic and then they go in
and all these people get [ __ ] over
without yelp and things like that in the
past they could just
keep living doing this [ __ ] yeah it's
great but but
unfortunately the devil's in the details
with yelp because they have been
they have been known to extort certain
businesses to pay
to have like you know to get to the top
and then like
if if you want um certain
like access to their services like you
have to pay even more and like
there's a great documentary about it
called the red mafia i think
about yelp and how they've had some
[ __ ] up business practices themselves
but i like the idea of it that the
people can can all come together and say
like yo we like this or we don't
yeah i think that for something like
this there should be
proof you know obviously
he was filming a video so he did show
that's all right but that's how
[ __ ] up that is right because you can
just all you have to do is go that
that that and that's proof and then you
just this is gone that's what you're
looking at
yeah and that's not true yeah so this is
the youtuber
he doesn't look so happy anymore and
this is a still from the video so
this is like what one of the dishes not
the best photo but
this is the from the still looks good
looks pretty gross
i wouldn't eat there i would not eat
there i'm gonna eat that it's really
good i love it i'm just kind of [ __ ]
around
no you seem pretty serious yeah why i
wouldn't eat there though because the
quality of the picture looks so good
like the video camera qualities
i'm like yeah it's a pretty solid video
so let's say
in this situation it wasn't based off of
that accusation but he reviewed it and
he says this is disgusting i don't like
this place
and they lost business because of that
reason right
would that be defamation still no
because at that point it's an opinion
it's not
lying yeah because i'm saying they they
are reusing
food that's a lie and like you have no
no proof on it
and it's damaging yeah and that's
damaged food critics are a whole
industry
that's true you're allowed to not like
something but they should be based on
your preferences not because they're
doing something disgusting and immoral
how about the about the the technicality
of what if he said
i think they were using the food because
that's what it seems like he said
so it's still like his his own
assumption does that technically count
as like
i don't know i think that there's a
there's a little bit of a like he's a
bit of a coward then because if you're
gonna say something like that to your
camera why can't you say it to the
people and
actually get an explanation for putting
the video out because if there was hair
in my thing
i would flag them down and be like come
on guys but also the culture these days
is like oh look what they did and
everyone's like why don't you go talk to
the manager and get it corrected they
they want that social media cloud and
that juice and the
drama what's happened to us in our
businesses too
where it's like you know we asked the
team and they're like no they were
completely happy we asked them is
everything okay and they're like fine
and then they go home and write a
negative review
and then we reach out and we'll be like
hey like i thought
it was all sorted out and like well i
had time to think about it and so and so
and then i felt different it's like
we'll come back to the shop and let us
make it right for you
and then you know it's remedied but i
feel like conflict resolution wise
people are very spineless
yes like they don't know how to just hey
i'm a customer and i'm unhappy with your
service
this is how i feel right well it's like
what mike tyson said about social media
he said it made it so a lot of people
can talk a lot of [ __ ] and never get
punched in the face
and so now you know yeah people just
feel like they can just say whatever the
[ __ ] they want on social media
and tough [ __ ] [ __ ] it's even hell
like
you can't do anything about it so yeah i
think it's it's all about consequences
right so like if people
like him were getting in trouble maybe
he had to pay a ton of [ __ ] money
now to help remedy this then
tubers will think twice about you know
making these accusations
before they go out and review a business
or whatever yeah true
so they're not they're not reopening
they're done um as far as i know that's
where the story ends
i'm not sure if they've opened i don't
know if there's going to be any
consequences
for this youtuber we should put this
guy's balls in a basket of angry craps
you know what i do love though is like
our friends um
losing luggage or anything like like
from airlines
and it's they're like i didn't want to
[ __ ] do this but i have to call your
ass out
whatever airline youtube and then they
immediately start responding because the
pool and i'm like
why couldn't you just have good customer
service why did you have to [ __ ] wait
until someone with a big
following calls your ass out and then
you have to scrounge up
how to [ __ ] fix this [ __ ] because
they only care about the pr
we all know that i mean right talk to
spectrum dude try calling those [ __ ]
like they [ __ ] hate you they hate you
on the phone they hate you on the emails
they hate you the whole time
they hate you that you use their service
they [ __ ] hate you but
when they advertise to you or like when
they're on the twitters and all this
stuff
they kind of like you and so you're like
i think they like
me when you're about to cancel their
service and they want you to stay
that's when they really love you well
drop it by 50
and give you a phone line they're like a
terrible wife or husband who's like
like you know i want a divorce like no
no i'll do i'll do good i'll buy a new
car
yeah god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you